you're looking great oh thank you yeah
ginger magic
yes always been a ginger do you like
being a ginger
i do but we're a dying breed apparently
yes i keep hearing that
we should mate to save the species
[Applause]
why are you backing off of that right
away i haven't done anything
but okay uh yeah we uh you know so much
stuff but first of all i saw you
and your husband sasha baron cohen yes
like a couple of weeks ago
i was out at a restaurant and i run into
you too yes
and uh that's never happened before i
don't go out a lot no we don't either
and um i i go out and i see you i run
right into you guys and we start
chatting
and then i think you mentioned something
about how you're you're sometimes
embarrassed to go out with
your husband and i'm thinking why would
he seems like such a funny guy
and seems like a great guy i gotta be
honest conan there are a lot of social
faux pas
i mean when we first came to hollywood
we went to this uh film premiere that
jack black
you know was producing a movie and
invited us and we arrived and
this lady stood up and made a really
long speech she was a biggest lady in
her 60s
and then jack black got up and made a
short speech and we watched the whole
film and afterwards we were
congratulating him
and you know jack black said yeah if i'd
known the movie was going to be so great
i would have made a longer speech
and then sasha said yeah like that woman
who wouldn't shut up with the massive
boobs
and then jack said that was my mom
and then sasha says well big boobs are
great isla wants big boobs
you want big boobs right babe i was
saying it was just worse he's digging
the hole deeper and deeper and deeper
and also he's someone who professionally
probably doesn't he doesn't feel
embarrassment the way the rest of us do
no no he really doesn't
yeah he really doesn't so he's going to
finish you in this town
yeah he really he has already sacha
baron cohen
uh he has work that is
can push is maybe sometimes on the line
sometimes he likes to step over the line
uh in a delightful way a very funny man
but i'm wondering what's it like if
you're with your family
and you're watching your husband's work
or one of his movies
and it's one of those scenes that he's
kind of famous for
how does that go over with your crowd i
got a couple of uh memories there
uh once is the the premiere of bruno in
london where i sat next to my mom
and during one particular scene my
husband's
character gives a [ __ ] to
the air but he mimes mimes it but in an
incredibly authentic way and i just was
staring
at the screen and i could feel my mom's
eyes turned to me at one point sort of
boring into me like really you marry
you really this is it that
and uh anyway it was hilarious and then
another time my dad bless his heart and
his wife came to
cape town where my husband was shooting
a movie and
wanted to have a set visit and i didn't
check the call sheet as one
you know doesn't think it's right you
know and we
we showed up on set and there were there
were these elephants in the distance
and i said to my kids and my dad and
everyone look guys that's where they're
filming let's go over and see what's
happening and
so we went over there in the buggy and
my husband was inside an animatronic
elephant's vagina
and another elephant was having sex with
another robotic elephant was having sex
with my husband while he was sort of
masturbating it was a bakati
party of elephants some were real some
were
fake i was like i can't explain this to
the kids let alone my dad
i just said let's get lunch let's get
lunch
well i don't think lunch would have been
the transition there
i remember that scene i remember that
scene uh really well that's a shocking
scene
yes grimsby the brothers grimsby where
he he climbs
into the female and it's
one of the most insane scenes and
produces sperm something i cannot do
okay you got us back on that cut we were
safely away
yeah i would think when you visit you
know for someone
to visit just so many scenes you could
have dropped in on
where he think about the movie you're
right
are there actually anything okay you're
right i was thinking about it
i was thinking is there a scene where
sasha's just having tea and talking to
another character no
no no i think there's sperm in every
[Laughter]
scene